m
y tenían sus libros de texto abiertos
sobre sus pupitres iban anotando en sus
libretas todo lo que yo iba escribiendo
en la pizarra
pero había una chica al fondo de la
clase que tenía hasta cada subirlos y se
distraía a mí mirando por una ventana
que nada al exterior
yo era un joven profesor y muy novato y
me fui poniendo cada vez más nerviosa
dejé la tiza encima de mi mesa me fui
acercando hacia ella
y conmigo línea de vídeo
qué es eso tan interesante que hay al
otro lado de la ventana imagino que será
mucho más importante que el examen que
tenemos las manos las chicas
y me respondió me dijo
la vida
fueron
dos palabras pero me destrozados como
una bomba de napa que lo arrastra
absolutamente todo a su paso
porque esas palabras me hicieron
reflexionar me mostraron que sin darme
cuenta había convertido mi aula en una
caverna
platón escribió una famosa alegoría
sobre unos prisioneros que se encuentran
desde su nacimiento encarcelados en el
interior de una caverna obligados a
contemplar una pared
en esa misma gruta se encuentran otros
hombres encargados de proyectar sombras
sobre esa pared
esas sombras son la única realidad que
conocen esos prisioneros a quienes jamás
se le ha mostrado el mundo real
pero uno de ellos queda libre se le
concede la gracia de conocer la realidad
y al salir de la caverna
lo primero que descubre es que todo lo
que he aprendido allí nada nada tiene
que ver con la vida
ese hombre libre es un filósofo
alguien que a pesar de haber descubierto
la verdad siente que tiene la necesidad
de volver de nuevo a la caverna a
rescatar a sus compañeros
contemple mi aula
una pizarra llena de palabras extrañas
que parecían sombras sobre la pared de
una caverna contemplé a mis alumnos
parecían prisioneros mis prisioneros
encarcelados
en sus pupitres obligados a continuar
mirando un encerado sobre el que ya
llevaba meses escribiendo cosas que poco
o nada tenían que ver con sus vidas los
profesores o presionados a veces con el
cumplimiento del programa oficial
corremos el peligro de convertir
nuestras aulas en cavernas desconectadas
absolutamente de los problemas y las
inquietudes de nuestros alumnos esas dos
palabras la vida me hicieron reflexionar
es decir me doblaron y me obligaron a
volverme hacia atrás al origen a la
fuente
sócrates ha sido siempre para mí un
referente un modelo como hombre como
ciudadano y como filósofo
pero sócrates no era un profesor de
filosofía
sócrates era un trabajador de la
construcción que practicaba la filosofía
no en una aula sino en la calle en los
mercados y las plazas de atenas
dialogando con sus vecinos acerca de la
justicia del bien y de la verdad
sócrates me enseñó
que realmente la filosofía nunca nació
en una aula sino que también perteneció
siempre a la calle
así que
desde esa clase cerré el libro de texto
borre la pizarra y salimos a la calle
salimos a un parque nos sentamos allí
sobre el césped y le pregunté a mis
alumnas acerca de cuáles eran realmente
los problemas que les inquietaban las
preguntas que realmente querían resolver
y ese día la clase me la dieron ellos a
mí porque era yo ahora quien callaba y
quién tomaba nota en mi libreta
y estas fueron algunas de las preguntas
que mis alumnos me transmitieron
preguntas que forman parte del libro que
ustedes tienen hoy en sus manos
cuando debemos obedecer desobedecer a la
autoridad
porque existe el bullying cuál es la
raíz del mal en el ser humano
como convencer a alguien de que no se
suicide
qué hay de bueno en ser normal quién
decide qué es lo normal
por qué angustia tener que elegir es
posible no elegir
cómo se afronta una ruptura sentimental
o la muerte de un ser querido
cuanta de la información que consumimos
es propaganda
debe un hombre ser feminista
como sabes que tus palabras significan
lo mismo en la mente de la persona que
las oye es lo mismo decir te quiero que
yo también
las galas de 'operación triunfo' son
arte
mis alumnos me recordaron que la
filosofía es un arte de preguntar
es un ejercicio una práctica que tiene
más que ver con eso con hacer preguntas
la filosofía no es un amor a la
respuesta eso sería un dogmatismo que
conduce la estupidez la filosofía es un
amor a la pregunta platón en el banquete
nos recuerda que la palabra que sócrates
usa para hablar de amor es erótica que
guarda un gran parecido con esta otra er
otan que significa hacer preguntas
pareciera que el viejo maestro quiere
recordarnos que la filosofía es un amor
no a la respuesta sino la pregunta
porque la filosofía siempre ha tenido
que ver con eso con la pregunta con
derribar muros con preguntas derribar
nuestros muros mentales con preguntas
derribar nuestros prejuicios y nuestros
dogmas con preguntas
pero el filósofo no se queda ahí
cuestionando lo todo y a todos con sus
insidiosas preguntas
una vez que el filósofo lo ha puesto
todo absolutamente todo patas arriba se
esfuerza con todo su ser en gozar de
esta vida consciente de la fugacidad del
tiempo así la filosofía aunque comienza
siendo un arte de preguntar termina
siendo un arte de vivir es decir de
tener el coraje de construirse uno mismo
la propia existencia y dotarla de
sentido
heidegger afirmaba que la mayoría de los
hombres viven existencias anónimas es
decir viven en un se dice y en un se
hace
dicen lo que dicen porque es lo que todo
el mundo dice y hacen lo que hacen
porque es lo que la gente hace y frente
a esto no les gustaría tener existencias
auténticas
no les gustaría empezar a decir y hacer
lo que solo ustedes puede llegar a decir
y hacer
vamos a seguir permitiendo que sean
otros los que nos dicten cómo tenemos
que pensar o cómo tenemos que vivir nos
atreveremos por fin
a pensar por nosotros mismos en este
mundo actual monocolor en cuanto a las
formas y los modos de vida necesitamos
hoy más que nunca héroes filosóficos que
tengan el coraje de encarnar la libertad
de pensamiento que se atrevan a pensar
la vida y a vivir el pensamiento porque
como decía sócrates una vida que no se
cuestiona una vida que no se examina una
vida que no se reflexiona no merece la
pena ser vivida
en los años 70 un fotógrafo tomó esta
icónica imagen del filósofo michel
foucault haciendo filosofía en plena
calle con un altavoz en la mano con los
trabajadores de la renault que se
encontraban en huelga
foucault nos recordó que la filosofía no
sólo pertenece al aula sino también a la
calle foucault nos enseñó que la
filosofía tiene que estar presente en
los nuevos espacios hoy nuestro teléfono
móvil es una puerta que da a la calle a
esa plaza pública virtual donde los
ciudadanos hoy nos encontramos para
seguir debatiendo y de alojando
construyendo ciudad y democracia juntos
por eso creo que si hoy sócrates tuviese
un móvil estaría presente en las redes
sociales obligándonos a pensar con sus
preguntas y esa es la razón por la cual
desde hace años utilizó twitter para
lanzarle todos los días a mis alumnos
una pregunta con la que cuestionarse la
realidad y el mundo en el que viven
el mundo digital dejo ya hace mucho
tiempo de ser un mundo aparente para
convertirse en el lugar donde mis
alumnos viven por eso creo que la
filosofía tiene que estar presente en
ese mundo
primero cuestionando las respuestas
obvias es decir aquellas a las que ya
nadie pide ni argumentos ni evidencias
segundo cuestionando y luchando en
contra de la estupidez es decir luchando
en contra de las pseudociencias luchando
en contra de la fec news de los
fascismos y de los populismos enemigos
todos de la democracia
y tercero recordándonos que la apelación
a las emociones se ha usado siempre para
generar masas en las que el individuo
deja de pensar y ser libre en nuestras
manos está siempre lo ha estado la
posibilidad de convertir las redes en
ágoras democráticas o callejones oscuros
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]